[Music]
today I'm going to talk to you about
sketching electronics I'm among several
other things an electrical engineer and
that means that I spend a good amount of
time designing and building new pieces
of technology and more specifically
designing and building electronics and
what I've found is that the process of
designing and building electronics is
problematic in all sorts of ways so it's
a really slow process it's really
expensive and the outcome of that
process namely electronic circuit boards
are limited in all sorts of kind of
interesting ways so they're really small
generally they're square and flat and
hard and frankly most of them just
aren't very attractive and so my team
and I have been thinking of ways to
really change and mix up the process and
the outcome of designing electronics and
so what if you could design and build
electronics like this so what if you
could do it extremely quickly
extremely inexpensively and and maybe
more interestingly really fluidly and
expressively and even improvisationally
wouldn't that be so cool and wouldn't
that open up all sorts of new
possibilities I'm gonna share with you
two projects that are investigations
along these lines and we'll start with
this one
[Music]
pretty cool huh we think so so now that
we developed these tools and found these
materials that let us do these things we
started to realize that essentially
anything that we can do with paper
anything that we can do with a piece of
paper in a pen we can now do with
electronics so the next project that I
want to show you is kind of a deeper
exploration of that possibility and I'll
kind of let it speak for itself
[Music]
[Applause]
so the next step for us in this process
is now to find a way to let all of you
build things like this and so the way
that we're approaching that is by kind
of teaching workshops to people where we
explain how they can use these kinds of
tools and then also working to get the
tools and the materials and techniques
kind of out into the real world in a
variety of ways and so sometimes soon
you'll be able to play and build and
sketch with electronics in this
fundamentally new way so thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]